the people who have had alien abductions
they feel like they can't share this
with anybody because they're going to be
labeled as crazy they might lose their
job they might get divorced what do you
consider the most credible account of
one of these visits Travis Walton his
friends were looking at going to jail
they thought that they killed him when
he was missing and he was missing for a
number of days he pops back up there's
the Betty and Barney Hill case I find
that to be very very credible case wait
Betty and Barney were their names was
that before The Flintstones and that's
why the Flintstones named which came
first that must have been a little like
nod to that in the cartoon and
eventually an alien did visit the
cartoon